[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا مباشره عقد قران
الامير الحسين ورجوه السيف طبعا مبروك
للعروسين مبروك للاردن وايضا السعوديه على
هذا الزواج الميمون امتزجت من خلال مراسم
حفل الزفاف التقاليد الاردنيه الزغروته
كانت رئيسيه في بعد الاعلان عن الزواج
وايضا البروتوكولات الخاصه بالاعراس
الملكيه الهاشميه
الاردنيه اذا نشاهد الان هذه الصور
للمباركه للعروسين من قبل الشخصيات
الرسميه التي شاركت وجاءت بالحضور طبعا
اخو العاهل الاردني اضافه الى شخصيات اخرى
الشيخه موزه شاهدنا ايضا السيده الاولى
زوجه الرئيس الامريكي بايدن ايضا كانت
حاضره من لبنان ايضا وغيرها من الشخصيات
المختلفه طبعا
بعد تقديم التهنئه للعروسين طبعا ستكون
هناك
سيكون هناك بالاحرى موكب
سيجول العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
لتقديم التحيات من قبل الشعب الاردني
والتهنئه طبعا للعروسين الامير الحسين
ورجوه ال سيف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات